Speaker 1: One of the really worrying trends
in the United States right now, really under
this new modern Republican Party.
Call it whatever you want to jump in or whatever
the case may be.
The thing is that facts truly do not matter
anymore.
And rewriting history to suit whatever point
you're trying to make today, it has become
a completely acceptable means to an end.
It doesn't matter how you rewrite history.
It doesn't matter what lie you tell about
the past.
As long as it supports whatever point you're
trying to make today, it's OK for this modern
Republican Party.
Here is one new example.
From the 4th of July weekend, Donald Trump's
former press secretary, Kayleigh McEnany,
appeared on Fox News and the context was making
the point that conservatives are victims and
that Democrats are unpatriotic.
And Kaili wildly claimed that the founding
fathers, the main founding fathers, were all
against slavery.
This is a lie.
It's just a big fat lie.
And we're going to look at what she said.
And the context was that Democratic Congresswoman
Corey Bush said that July 4th is sort of a
celebration for white people.
Corey Bush said when they say that the Fourth
of July is about American freedom, remember,
the freedom they're referring to is for white
people in the sense that we are celebrating
the anniversary of a country which at year
one, the date that is being celebrated was
one in which black people were enslaved in
the United States.
That's the context.
OK, let's look at what Kayleigh McEnany had
to say about it,
Speaker 5: starting with you, Bill Bennett.
The haters never take a day off from hating.
That is clear.
And they never take a day off of getting the
facts wrong.
We know most of our forefathers, all of our
main founding fathers were against slavery.
Recognize the evils of it.
There's a great piece to that end on Heritage
called 1776, not sixteen 19.
But I'll leave it to you.
You know, they're so wrong and so much where
to begin.
Speaker 1: So that is completely untrue.
OK, that's really, really, really not true.
Let's actually go through this because there's
there's an opportunity to actually learn a
little something here.
The majority of the founding fathers of the
United States owned slaves.
Now, you could say, well, they owned them,
but they were against it.
We're going to come back to that.
OK, but but they were not against it enough
not to have their own slaves.
Now, I'm talking about Benjamin Franklin,
John Hancock, John John Jay, Thomas Jefferson,
James Madison, George Washington and many
others.
They they owned slaves.
Some of the names you might not recognize
as readily.
There were a few founding fathers that did
not own slaves, John Adams and Samuel Adams
in Massachusetts, for example, Thomas Paine,
I don't believe is known to have owned slaves.
OK, so when Kayleigh McEnany says most of
the founding fathers were against slavery,
mostly they owned slaves.
Now, what is true is that over time, many
founding fathers, including some that owned
slaves, started to recognize some problems
with slavery.
Some realized, rightly, that slavery was antithetical
to the concept of freedom and liberty on which
the US was supposedly based.
But some of them seemed more to be thinking
about it.
Almost like economically.
Thomas Jefferson condemned the injustice of
the slave trade in the initial draft of the
Declaration of Independence.
But there are counter points about whether
did that mean he was against slavery or did
he just not like the slave trade as it was
being carried out internationally?
So even that I mean, I'm sure people will
write in and say, no, David, that's super
clear.
It was either this or it was that.
There's there's some ambiguity to it.
But he owns slaves.
And then you had some who really wanted to
change nothing about whether slavery was federally
legal and just say it's a state issue.
Now, if, for example, slave owner Benjamin
Franklin, slave owner owner Benjamin Franklin
in Pennsylvania, supported anti slavery causes,
but not federally, you know, if if South Carolina
wants to keep having slaves, will, that's
their thing.
But in Pennsylvania, we shouldn't have slaves
necessarily.
So to call that being antislavery again, that
this is pretty nebulous in many ways.
So the point here is, was the opinion on slavery
of the founding fathers maybe more complex
than they were either for it or against it?
Absolutely.
Did some founding fathers have seemingly inconsistent
positions on slavery?
Absolutely.
Did some of them change their views on slavery
over time?
Yes, no doubt about it.
But as Kayleigh McEnany right when she says
most of the founding fathers were against
slavery, no, that's a complete and total lie.
And the point here of what Kayleigh McEnany
did was simply to try to attack Quarrie Bush
by saying when Corie Bush says July 4th really
celebrates freedom for white people because
at the time black people were enslaved, Kayleigh
wants to say, well, no, we're the founding
fathers.
We're all against slavery, and that is simply
inaccurate, and so her entire defense falls
apart.
Now, whether you agree that July 4th is a
pro slavery holiday or a celebration of an
era when there was slavery, you know that
that's a debate.
That's a debate you can have and you can say,
well, OK, yes, we're celebrating the anniversary
of a date at which there was slavery.
We no longer have that.
We can still recognize that this is a milestone
in the existence of the country without being
in agreement with all the things that the
country did at the time.
Right.
Then you're in the weeds, you're in the details.
But Kayleigh McEnany is just wrong.
And this is the exact type of little pithy
talking point that the average Fox News viewer
will never investigate and will simply start
to repeat and repeat and repeat.
It's sad more than anything else.